when you look at this inner quantity
here cosine inverse of X this is just
another way of saying cosine of what
angle equals x and so you can see if you
take the cosine inverse of both sides of
this equation see cosine inverse of
cosine theta is equal to cosine inverse
of ax you can see I just took the cosine
verse of both sides these are inverses
that gives us our angle by itself theta
which is equal to cosine inverse of ax
so I just wanted to show you this is
just another way of writing this but
what you do now is you would construct a
triangle okay a right triangle and
you're saying the cosine of theta is
equal to X now anything can be written
as a fraction by putting it over one
right so you can say the cosine of theta
is equal to the adjacent over the
hypotenuse so cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse remember the so Toa acronym
remember so cosine is adjacent divided
by hypotenuse but now what we want to do
is we want to find that missing side in
this right triangle and we can use the
Pythagorean theorem to do that so what
we have here is a squared plus B squared
equals C squared C of course is the
hypotenuse that's one squared let's call
this a so this is x squared plus B
squared so to solve for B now we're
going to subtract x squared from both
sides of the equation we've got B
squared equals one minus x squared and
if we take the square root of both sides
you can see that B equals the square
root of 1 minus x squared so I'm going
to put that right here for our missing
side so now what we're figuring out is
what's the tangent of this angle so
tangent is the opposite side over the
adjacent right Kandace opposite /
adjacent so this is going to be square
root of 1 minus x squared divided by X
and you can see we've gone from a trig
function here to an algebraic expression
and you've got it so let's look at
another example see if you can do this
one we've got the sine of tangent
inverse of square root of x over 3 now
just again a quick refresher tangent
inverse of square root of x over 3 is
another way of saying tangent of what
angle equals square root of x divided by
3 C because if we take the tangent
inverse of both sides that's going to be
theta
equals tangent inverse of X over three
so we're gonna go ahead and construct
our triangle now right triangle here's
our angle theta tangent is the opposite
side over the adjacent side so that's
how we get square root of x over three
now we're going to do our Pythagorean
theorem a squared plus B squared equals
C squared a is three so that's going to
be three squared plus here's our side B
square root of x squared equals our
hypotenuse C squared so we have 9 plus
the square and square root those cancel
so that gives us x equals C squared
if we take the square root of both sides
you can see that C is equal to the
square root of 9 plus X so that's going
to be this side right here 9 plus X but
we want to find out what's the sine of
this angle well sine remember is
opposite over hypotenuse so we have
square root of x over square root of I'm
just gonna interchange these because
addition is commutative X plus 9 now you
might not want to leave the square root
in the denominator like this so let's go
ahead and rationalize by multiplying by
square root of x plus 9 over square root
of x plus 9 C we're multiplying the
numerator the denominator by the same
thing so it's just like multiplying by
one so it doesn't change the value it's
just going to change the way that this
looks so it's the square root of x
squared plus 9x I'm just multiplying
these together distributing all divided
by square root of x plus 9 times square
root of x plus 9 is just going to be X
plus 9 and you've got it so if you want
to see more about trigonometry I'm gonna
put a playlist right there that you can
check out this channel is all about
helping you to raise your grade pass
your class and go on to pursue your
dreams and my goal is to help you do
that so I'll look forward to seeing the
future videos I'll talk to you soon